vamos a ver cuánto es un tercio entre
cinco y te voy a dar una pista intenta
dibujar un tercio y después dividirlo en
cinco partes iguales pausa el vídeo e
intenta resolverlo bien vamos a trabajar
juntos y como prometí o más bien como te
sugerir dibujaremos un techo así que si
este cuadrado representa un entero y lo
parto en tres secciones iguales
intentaré que sean lo más parecidas
posibles de modo que supongamos que son
exactamente iguales ahora un tercio es
una de esas tres secciones por lo que
aquí tenemos un tercio y quiero
dividirlo en cinco secciones iguales
como voy a dividir entre cinco un tercio
bueno voy a aprovechar para dividir todo
en cinco secciones igual es
esencialmente voy a hacer cinco filas
intentaré hacerlo lo mejor posible una
dos tres cuatro cinco filas iguales es
decir tome este entero y lo divide entre
cinco partes ahora si me fijo el
ministerio original y tomo sólo una
quinta parte de él me quedaría solo esta
sección de azul qué fracción representa
esta sección de azul de me entero
original bueno lo que hice fue dividir
el entero en 15 secciones iguales como
lo sé bueno podríamos contar las 1 2 3 4
5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 o podemos
decir que tenía 123 tercios y los he
dividido en 1 2 3 4 5 partes iguales
entonces 3 por 5
me quedan 15 secciones por lo tanto cada
una de estas secciones es un quinceavo
es decir un tercio entre 5 va a ser un
15 amo un quinceavo y por lo tanto un
tercio entre 5 es igual
un quinceavo y hemos acabado hasta la
próxima